brian stelter i think is one of the
worst people on tv because he provides
cover for them as this media reporter
who's constantly i'll tell you this
i i've known brian for a long time not
like i've known him well or anything but
it's amazing how he went from being a
media reporter for the new york times to
the fox news review show for cnn sunday
mornings
that's what he does he watches fox news
and then he writes about it and does a
show where he's like tucker carlson had
an opinion about waffles today and it's
like i did if i want to hear tucker's
opinion i'll just ask him he did a whole
piece on the fact that fox news
personalities weren't admitting that
they were getting
the vaccinations like they weren't doing
their vaccinations selfies did you
violate policy by speaking on this show
that you got the vaccine well i put it
out there i actually put my vaccination
on social media because i'm very open
with having ms and i'm someone that you
know should get the vaccine just for
that very reason that i have a
compromised immune system so i was out
there and i put it on social media and
then of course he's like well there's no
fox personalities that are putting out
their vaccination selfies and i i just
was like i did this three weeks ago am i
not a fox and friends personality you
know
you are
but it's bad for their narrative
so well we don't mean the the the
meteorologist the weather lady no no no
no we mean uh the uh
pundits
hannity
we want hannity to do it that was weird
when he did that morale it was like a um
like a brow beating or like a like a
what would you call it like a morality
where it's like well
yeah like a guilt by like we got the
thing where is everyone else getting it
like a peer pressure and at the time
when he talked about that a lot of
people weren't allowed to get the
vaccination because there was a
hierarchy because of andrew cuomo who
could get the vaccination so
stelter puts it out out there on social
media like why aren't these fox
personalities going to get vaccinations
but at the time we actually couldn't get
them because we weren't
a lot of them weren't of the age or
wasn't it specifically why aren't they
posting vaccine selfies yes what the
so i don't know if you're familiar with
freedom tunes
at all no uh so our friend sheamus he
has a channel on youtube he makes these
little uh he makes these you know
political uh cartoons and one of them is
a guy going to the doctor to get his
vaccine and the doctor is like do you
want to take the vaccine selfie and he's
like no no i don't need a self and he
was uh okay
and then later on kovid shows up at his
house like the actual virus and he's
like i'm here to get you and the guy
goes kovit you can't get me i've got a
vaccine and he goes what show me your
show me your proof and he shows him the
vaccine card he goes i'm not that i want
to see your vaccine selfie everybody
knows you know so
that was the plan cnn my head is
exploding it's just ridiculous if that's
what you're bugging us about not having
a coveted vaccine it's also a health
issue you know health information you
don't you don't necessarily have to put
that out there at all why are you brow
beating people for
because there's health information out
there they they want to push the
narrative that all of fox knows his
viewers are anti-vaxxers or they
are conspiracy theorists or q a or
whatever the stuff and it's it's not
true
i have been at home broadcasting
you know in my spare bedroom and my
house for over a year now and when i
went in and said listen i'm compromised
i probably should stay home they were
like of course you need to take care of
your health and you know they've always
been like that
it's really
disappointing i guess to say uh creepy
if you watch cnn
and you never watch fox news they
probably think it's a bunch of people
walking around in clan hoods with covid
and other diseases and like no vaccines
and
there's just like this uh hive of scum
and villainy in new york city surrounded
by gates that no one can get into or
something because like people got to
realize that fox news the like uh the
building you work out particularly is in
new york under the rules of cuomo and de
blasio so certainly they're taking it
seriously because they legally have to
what's the history of fox do you guys
know much about it like how it got
started when it got started roger ailes
he was the he was the mastermind behind
fox news and um
he was uh
he helped a lot of
political people uh with their careers
in politics
and he was the one who kind of decided
with rupert murdoch that there needed to
be a
a television
station cable news network that
represented people that didn't feel that
they were being represented
and so that was um
i think almost 25 years ago it was like
95 or something i think i you know i'll
have to do some rings i've been i've
this is my 18th year so i think we're
coming up on 25. so yeah murdock had
started fox
like fox had been around for what since
the 80s or something
fox like the the fox tv show is that
what it was and then ales came to
murdoch and was like let's news channel
okay yeah
i'll have to see the chicken or the egg
is isn't fox news like uh is it still
owned by murdoch it's because it it
didn't go with fox and the disney deal i
guess so it's like no we're our own
separate entity now how is it working at
fox news
i love it i've been there like i said
for 18 years it's the best job i've ever
had
i love the people there
i love the job that i do you know the
fact that i talk about andrew cuomo is
you know
i've never thought i would ever be in
this kind of position talking about
politics because that's not you know my
wheelhouse at all you know they don't
they don't have an issue with like you
coming on shows like this and talking
you know i think that they knew that
this was very personal for me they knew
the story
and at the very beginning when this was
happening my husband who's a very
private person
not in broadcasting at all he didn't
want me to bring up his family
you know they were very private people
but when we saw the fact that there was
no news out there
and the governor was going around
as the go-to pandemic politician not
talking about these nursing home issues
it just it became more and more clear
that he was getting away with this so
you talk about tucker i was texting with
tucker and
i believe um
it was a conservative uh
was it uh town hall maybe
forgive me but it was a conservative
outlet that that that broke the news
that he wasn't counting those that died
in the hospitals okay i think it was
town hall i think it was town hall too
no what's what was the outlet that
tucker carlson started daily caller
daily caller it was a daily caller
forgive me so they were the ones doing
the investigative reporting and i was
reading this and thinking to myself why
isn't this a story on the on the news
channels so i texted with him and i said
listen this is what happened with my
in-laws um
he he put coveted positive patients into
nursing homes he actually had a mandate
for 46 days to do this um this should be
a story and and i he said listen if you
want to anytime you want to come on the
program i believe it's a story
you have a forum to do so um and when i
continuously saw the governor going on
these programs and never being asked the
nursing home question that's when i said
to my husband you know
can we can i talk about this because i
don't think there's anyone doing that uh
and so that's how it sort of began
and i haven't really stopped i'd like to
but uh
it's still to this day you know he seems
to be getting away with it i think he's
gonna get away with it i mean maybe
maybe he won't get reelected but i don't
think he's gonna get in trouble but you
know
you don't think so
yeah what about the harassment you know
i started maybe
you know there are a lot of democrats
that don't like them and so that's why
when all the harassment stuff was coming
out i thought that that's why they're
jumping on this bandwagon because they
they the the really criminal stuff is
the nursing homes but they can get
behind the metoo
uh stuff because that's a little bit
easier to digest i guess to go after the
governor for the metoo stuff
um but i mean there's nine women now he
keeps going on and and putting his
you know his his foot in his mouth
there's a an apparent impeachment
process going on with
uh albany lawmakers but i don't i think
it's a sham so maybe you're right but
you know what
if it means that he is not re-elected
for a fourth term
then
then it was worth it something i guess
but i just
i don't expect any of these people to
ever be held accountable what if it was
a republican governor what if it was a
ron desantis that put covet positive
patients into nursing homes
nine thousand of them he covered up the
numbers he tried to sell a book for four
million dollars
you know prison right he'd be in an
orange jump dude probably not prison but
the the media would it they would run
for six months now it would be the top
story on every single cable news channel
this is the problem with
the the networks have built an audience
based on tribe because
i think mostly because of the internet
if people can choose to watch whatever
they want then they're going to choose
to go where their bias leads them so
cnn becomes the orange man bad network
now
everything they say has to be in line
with one particular world view
their writings are in the gutter on fire
because they've pigeonholed themselves
but i think they probably would have
went under a long time ago if they
didn't donald trump allowed them to stay
afloat for several years longer than
they should have
people watch that watch that network or
they used to just to hear
why trump was bad to prove to themselves
that he was bad now that trump is gone
what does cnn have to offer i mean they
used to go and do reporting they don't
really do that so much anymore i think
they're trying to again but
well to back to your point uh you know
fox has been really good to me and when
they knew my personal story and knew
what i was trying to do by going on you
know tucker show and sean hannity show
and fox and friends
it was to
be a voice for all of these families
that didn't have one so i do walk that
line sometimes
and i'm grateful that they gave me the
platform and trusted me that you know i
was doing it for the right reasons
you went on tucker's show and talked
about all this was that the first time
you had stepped away from just doing the
yes and it was terrifying it's still
terrifying yeah it's kind of it's kind
of it's kind of crazy i mean your whole
uh persona on fox is you walk outside
there's people there and you're like
how's it going welcome to new york yeah
yeah like how you like ask the kids like
what's it like in new york and then here
you are in this very serious political
fight also on tucker you know i can be
both of those people you know i can
still be the one that goes out there and
has fun and you know does the kentucky
derby and groundhog day and and write
the freddie the frog caster books for
the kids but i can also be a serious
person that wants to
um you know hold the governor's
feet to the fire and and try to make him
accountable for something that he did
wrong and that cost the lives of
thousands now everybody wants to know is
tucker a nice guy he's a lovely
wonderful guy yeah he's a good friend he
really is
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you